all right guys
bang bang i've got chris here with me
thanks so much for doing this man
oh man so happy to be on the show i love
it all right so people don't know this
but chris and i already did this one
time
and we screwed up the audio so we're
gonna do round two which means that now
i know all the secrets and can ask them
even better questions
um but uh you have a absolutely
fascinating story
that involves everything from going to
cornell uh
to ending up at olive garden and then
eventually being
kind of one of the power players in
hollywood let's just start with where
you grew up and how do you get to
cornell
yeah sure um i was born and raised in
south florida i was a big miami
hurricane fan as a kid
grew up on an island called singer
island which was sort of a
middle class upper middle class island
just north of palm beach
although i could walk down to the end of
our street and see the kennedy compound
down
on the other side of the inlet it was
sort of interesting it was like a
juxtaposed instead of the other side of
the tracks you were on the other side of
the palm beach inlet
um grew up uh the son of a father who
was an engineer at pratt whitney
my mom had various small businesses but
we were
we had pretty much everything we wanted
or everything we needed and some of what
we wanted
but they instilled really strong values
in me which actually i
write about in the book in particular
the art of networking which my dad
was extremely good at that i carried on
into my adulthood
when i was in high school he got
transferred to
connecticut for pratt whitney i went to
a
huge sort of john hughesian type of
breakfast club high school called
glastonbury high school um graduated
there and then went to cornell
actually with a with a rotc scholarship
um although i did the
the infamous one and run which i'm a
little ashamed of but
um um did get the first year for free
and did a lot of really interesting
stuff with the army during that year
um graduated with an engineering degree
uh it was 1993 the economy
was not good i mean nothing like covid
crisis bad but it just wasn't good
and i graduated in the middle of my
engineering class i think i had a 2.7
gpa
so i didn't have any job offers packed
up my car drove cross country looking
for a place to
settle my roots i stayed at fraternity
my fraternity house at various college
campuses across the country i think i
hit about 60 of them
um got to boulder thought that's where i
wanted to be because i loved big head
todd and the monsters and the samples
and all that great music and i was a big
skier
but ultimately there were just a lot of
phds with engineering degrees in that
town
uh pouring coffee so i moved on uh
visited a buddy in los angeles for a
weekend
realized it was 72 and sunny every day
here
beautiful people amazing things to do
you could literally surf in the morning
and go skiing in the afternoon i said
geez
i should live here and at the time it
was really interesting because no one
wanted to live here uh the defense
industry had all moved out
it was a pretty depressed uh economy
they had just survived fires in malibu
and in laguna beach um just prior to me
getting here there were floods
um i got here three weeks before the
earthquake which didn't scare me away i
still stayed
and got a job at olive garden in
westwood just just outside of ucla's
campus
and uh started being able to pay my
bills by having the ultimate in
hospitaliano
and in the book that's sort of where i
start my journey for
um anybody that that reads it it's uh
it's a colorful one
and it literally starts as i arrive at
the olive garden in westwood
i love that story so uh i grew up in a
family of five boys uh my parents are
both italian
and uh as kids we thought it was like
the most
you know uh the best restaurant we could
possibly go to was the olive garden
because you had the uh
the free salad and free bread sticks and
all this kind of stuff and
as we got older we realized that maybe
our parents had just tricked us into
what good italian food was but the olive
garden was a big fan favorite of my
house growing up
you know it's funny i also i talk to my
kids about it all the time because they
have such a different palette than i had
as a kid but for us
like that once a month or once every
couple months special occasion was going
to a tgi
tgi fridays or a benigns and then that
once a year special occasion was
benihana's
you know that was like that was as good
as it got for eating out
i love that um all right so you go from
olive garden to
eventually uh you break into william
morris
uh but do it in kind of a very um
non-traditional way walk us through like
why what
did you want to get into um you know
william morris but specifically just the
agencies and kind of the hollywood scene
well it's funny i mean you you talk
about uh not really having a master plan
just sort of looking for opportunities
as they present themselves and working
your butt off
and looking for opportunities as they
present just by
living life to its fullest and being
smart and learning every day
um that's sort of i guess what happened
to me i had no master plan
i was just trying to make ends meet as a
waiter at the olive garden
i met a couple guys there that were on a
double date with two girls one of them
happened to be
a guy that ran he had just left an
agency um it was icm at the time and was
becoming an independent producer and he
said well what are you gonna
do for the rest of your life and i said
i don't know i'm actually trying to
figure it out now and he said
well why not hollywood hollywood's the
wall street of the 90s and it was funny
in 1994
there had been a big slew of harvard
lampoon grads pre-existing
that came out for the pre-existing maybe
four or five years prior to my arrival
and they started taking over shows as
writers like seinfeld and so on
and um it became known as wall street of
the 90s to all the harvard grads and of
course i was a cornell grad a safety
school for them
um so i sort of discovered it from that
double date that i happened to walk in
on
and they invited me into this pickup
basketball league which was a who's who
of people that
no one knew back then but turned into
huge players in the business i mean
zarya emanuel and patrick whitesell
who were big sort of super agents matt
damon ben
affleck matthew mcconaughey a bunch of
actors no one knew of at the time but
were
on the rise so i got in there everybody
said get a job in the mail room
i wasn't the niece or nephew of any
famous director or
actor so getting into a mail room was
really difficult but i did get a temp
job at a company called career group i
don't know if exists anymore
but the temp job got me in the fax room
of the music department at william
morris and i was making 250 bucks a week
sending out riders for um acts such as
the eagles
nirvana pearl jam etc and the riders
were essentially the contract
perks and benefits that those bands
would have by performing at certain
shows and in fact
the eagles which was doing the hellish
freezes over tour back then
had a rider that cost 60 grand right
they're catering i think a loan was 40
000
backstage but anyway as i was doing that
and faxing out these things i started to
realize
how i could meet the right people to get
into the mail room
um and it took me six months but i met
all the right people
did all the right sort of things to get
there and then eventually
boom got promoted into the mail room at
william morris called up my parents i
was super excited i'm making 300 bucks a
week as a mail room clerk in the
william morris mail room they said why
are you excited about working in the
mail room of a cigarette company i said
no no no it's a talent agency this is
how you start david geffen blah blah
blah blah
and um that began my real career journey
away from
olive garden and into something that
actually led to something uh
um career worthy and and uh it was a
really really wild journey i became
um one of the youngest agents there for
quite a while
um and then it led into um as you know
from the book
a day that i got abruptly fired yeah and
so walk us through like while you were
at william morris you go from the mail
room to
a pretty senior position in terms of
just you got to see a lot of the
industry and the inner workings
uh what were some of the things that you
were doing before you left um well one
of the big things that i was doing i
became a tv syndication and cable agent
um which no one wanted to be but i had
this
mentor his name was jerry katzman he was
the vice chairman at the time
and he hired me to be his morning
assistant which meant
you had to get in at six a.m and and
work his desk
for european calls and whatever until
his normal assistant came in at nine
o'clock
and the reason i got that job is i went
to interview for it
and he looked at my suit and he said
where'd you get that suit and i said why
do you like it he's like
i guess where is it made and i said i
opened up the thing i said oh yugoslavia
and he goes where would you buy a
yugoslavian suit and i said well i went
up to hollywood and vine you know that
shop up there i got
i got this suit and a couple others he's
like how much did they cost and i said
well it was 99 bucks for all three and
he said you're hired
and i think what was great about that
moment is that he
was so used to you know uh we used to
call him trustafarians or or
kids that had all these different means
to get into the business
and when he heard i was like working at
the olive garden only six months before
and was a temp and all that kind of
stuff he was like oh this is a project i
can work with
so one day he said hey i know you're
working with motion picture agents on
their night desks
but if you want to really get promoted
you should go up and see this guy mark
itkin who's running tv
syndication and cable and i said i don't
even know what that is and he's like
just go up there and tell him that's all
you want to do for
your life and i said really he's like
yeah the goal is
to go from being an assistant to having
an assistant
as quickly as possible and that's where
you're going to be able to do it if
you're in motion pictures it's going to
take you forever
so i ended up taking them up on that
mark hired me and and
literally promoted me in 14 months and
the crazy part was is i started signing
these sketch comedy writers
out of shows like politically incorrect
saturday night live etc
and one of them was a guy named michael
mccullers
who was writing he was writing jokes for
the mtv movie awards and got to meet
this
actor named mike myers and they came up
with this idea called austin powers
so we went out and sold this script
austin powers and the next thing you
know i came across these guys brian
koppelman and david levine who are the
showrunners of billions but they wrote
this script called rounders which was a
poker
um script and we went out and sold that
and before i knew it
the motion picture department asked me
to join them and uh you know so the rest
was history i rose up through the ranks
in the motion picture business
for sure and and so you eventually end
up at um dmg which
uh maybe just give us kind of a quick
understanding of like
why is dmg important to kind of some of
the understandings you have
around us and china relationships yeah
so once again in the book i talk about
um
not really having well i thought i had a
master plan of
running william morris one day but that
um came to a quick end when i
politically fell out of favor with one
of my bosses and i tried something
to to get ahead and it just didn't work
so
i got thrown out of the company and
um literally it was one of those jerry
maguire moments where it seemed like all
i had was a
bag with a goldfish in it and you know
tried to get even my assistant to come
with me and he was like well i got a
good job here and i was like ah don't
worry about it you can stay
and when i feverishly was making the
phone calls
after that moment there was one client
that i had signed on a whim because i
saw this little movie it was called
cookers
that was financed out of china this
company
pacesetter productions um which was
formed by
two chinese citizens and one american
uh made the movie and you know they
directed edited it
produced it financed it etc and i
thought it was a really interesting
little film
so i signed them thinking maybe there's
something
that we can do together and then
ultimately i got fired
and they happened to be one of the only
clients that i called up and i said hey
you coming with me and they said
well we didn't even know you got fired
no one called us from william morris and
i said
great climb aboard and they sort of
became my rod
tidwell you know uh jerry maguire's sort
of
um you know uh client that he was able
to take but
really didn't wasn't sure wasn't going
to add up to anything or whatever
and you know just took it on a whim and
it was shortly there after that i went
over to china and i saw
what they were up to i saw what was
going on in that market
the national bird was called the crane
because there were cranes
literally everywhere um and in fact they
at the day i visited their office in
beijing
it was actually tarped over in the back
because
one night um the the zoning of the
development commission came through and
bulldozed half of their building away
because it happened to be on one
part of a of a new development region so
they sort of had half a building and
they were busy building another one that
they're going to move into and i said
wow this looks like a great opportunity
do you need me to do
more stuff for you rather than just like
looking for you know a director job or
something is there other
other you know parts that i can be
valuable with and they said
hey we don't have any eyes and ears in
north america can you help us build
business
and bring them to us in china so that we
can help them
sell their products and services in this
country and i said all day long
happy to do it let's do it so that sort
of kick-started that
opportunity and it really um
you know the world was your oyster when
it looked
when you looked at the china market it
just felt like you could make
trillions of dollars there but the
problem was
everybody always looked so far in the
future and how big it was
and one of the great things i learned
about working with them was
you had to you had to get baby steps
accomplished
every step of the way because you could
never skip
steps in that market but you also were
never able to go into cruise control
and just follow somebody else's lead
because almost
everything you did was historic it had
never been done before
so the idea was to do one project that
was relatively close to what the next
level project would be and sell whoever
you are selling to
hey we did this and we know we have all
the resources infrastructure
and wherewithal to do this believe us
and give us that opportunity and then
boom you do that one and then you go to
the next climbing of the
of the scale yeah and so i think a lot
of people are very
um uneducated or uh not informed at all
when it comes to
uh what this entails and so you know to
kind of level set
you're uh an american who was working
with
uh movies that want to get into china
and that seems like a pretty you know
rudimentary or elementary exercise until
you realize that
the chinese government and the chinese
culture is very specific and so you've
got to have an understanding of
um you know kind of what they're trying
to accomplish because ultimately you
actually need approval
right and so for the people listening to
this you're probably more familiar with
like the chinese uh the great firewall
so companies like facebook and google
are not in china
uh because they don't meet some level of
standards and so walk us through some of
the examples maybe of how
you being an american but understanding
the chinese culture and kind of the
government's
goals you would take a movie and
work with them to actually gain that
approval so that you could access this
market that had you know
over a billion people and kind of
represented a pretty material increase
in
in the financial performance of a film
yeah well um
well first of all you mentioned i'm
american and i
was living i was on a plane a lot but i
was living in the u.s because i was
really the conduit for the international
business that we were doing
on the ground in china and really the
translator of what we needed to get done
and
also the salesman of what we were comp
pushing over there etc
so one of the hard parts to to
understand is that
you'll never understand china like even
the chinese have a hard time
understanding china
but as an american especially one that
wasn't actually living there full time
there's a a glass ceiling that you hit
really hard
so my my feeling was like i needed to
understand the most macro basics
and then utilize that kiss principle
keep it simple stupid
to try to apply the macro to whatever we
were doing on the micro
so the best way i did it and i talk
about in a book is
is you got 1.4 billion people there 92
million of them are
ccp members but but there's 1.4 billion
people
and the leadership there the ccp is just
trying to keep those people
just happy enough that they don't revolt
they don't want another tn men square
incident
and the reason i say just happy enough
is because there's so many people there
if you made them all happy
the world would be swiss cheese there's
just not enough resources on earth for
that
so they gotta give them all of what they
need which is part of the
big push that they have to rid
themselves of extreme poverty which
they claim they've completely
accomplished and then
us so push as many people into the
middle class as possible
because that allows them all what they
need and some of what they want
and to date they've say they've brought
600 million into the middle class
which is an unbelievable number but that
still leaves another
800 million that aren't there so there's
two things one is
is when you're selling a product or a
service there
you need to think about that bringing
people into the middle class objective
um because that plays into people not
revolting
so part of that is when you bring a
product and service in there you want to
pitch the ccp
why that might actually help them
accomplish that goal
it's not beneficial to them just to let
the product and service in there
and have their consumers consume it
because that doesn't
help the middle class objective it's
better and this is why you see forced
jv's and tech swaps and various other
things
it's better to say hey let us bring in
this product and service
and we'll form joint ventures or we'll
do co-productions with you or we'll do
skill set exchanges or we'll do various
other things that allow you
and in particular in my business the
film industry to build your film
industry from a very
nascent fledgling industry to one that
can be world class and provide
lots of middle class jobs right so
everything we did
in the movie business had to do with
that idea that
you let this product in we're going to
help you fulfill that middle class
objective
and even if it wasn't quite as
practical or tangible of creating those
jobs
if you could create the uh messaging
that allowed them to message their
populace that hey
this is good for china because it's
going to help bring people into the
middle class
it's going to help showcase us as a
country of the future where people want
to do business where people want to
visit spend money
et cetera then that also satisfies their
objectives so
the goal was always to sell the ccp on
why to provide you access to their
consumer
number one and then once you got past
that then you had to sell all over again
to their consumer base and part of that
way that you
sold the product in service had to be
approved by the ccp
so you weren't just always focused on
the consumer at that point you were
focused on the consumer
figuring out what's going to get them
excited about that product and service
and then thinking how you're going to
pass it through the ministry of
propaganda and ccp so two entities you
had to sell to
but then one main entity that you always
had to think of and that's the ccp
so let's walk through a couple of these
examples right because um
maybe we could start with looper first
and really the idea here is to
uh highlight or illustrate like as
you're creating a movie we were talking
about actually
changing the content of the movie in
order to fulfill some of these goals of
the ccp
so tell us the looper story and kind of
how that came together
yeah the looper story it's a great case
study it's super colorful but it also is
a very applied practical
um case study that that handles a lot of
stuff that we just talked about the
previous five minutes
so with looper that's a movie it's a
sci-fi thriller if anybody hasn't seen
it that stars bruce willis and joseph
gordon-levitt and an actress named emily
blunt
um bruce willis plays the role of joseph
gordon-levitt 40 years in the future
so essentially the movie takes place in
a relative present day
and then also 40 years in the future the
original
script we thought was a really
interesting
sort of um mid-size it was roughly a 30
million dollar budget
that would work in that market with
consumers the problem was
there were a lot of censored items in it
number one is time travel
time travel or telling any story in the
future
is pretty much banned or censored by the
ccp
because the ccp is so careful about what
the narrative
is in regards to china as they move
forward into the future so they want to
dictate exactly what that messaging is
they have the same directive in regards
to anything that's told in the past or
in historic terms
or using time travel to go in the past
because they want to be very careful
about how they cultivated the messaging
of where they came from and where they
are and how they got to where they are
today
so that's that was a big one the second
one was
we wanted to shoot the movie in china
but the script took place in france in
the future
but in order to do it in china one of
the problems was is there was
crime on the ground in the future which
china doesn't like to showcase on their
own soil
and there was drug use and various other
uh activities that are
typically censored but we felt like if
we could
shoot the movie in china move the script
to china in the future
and showcase china in the way the ccp
would be proud of
we could eliminate all those issues with
the movie and actually get the win to
our back to release the film there
at an opportune time so we we started
with ryan johnson the director who now
directs a lot of the star wars movies
and we said to him hey your movie takes
place in france in the future
but france in the future who knows where
that's going to
be 40 years from now they could be
bankrupt who wants to live there blah
blah blah blah blah
china we know is going to be a major
behemoth 40 years from now so why not
move it to china oh that's interesting
and on top of it obviously we had a lot
of financial incentives to it
and we added production days to the
budget and ultimately ryan signed off on
it
so then what we did was we decided what
city do we want to showcase bruce willis
living in in the future and we decided
on shanghai
so then we worked with the shanghai
municipal government and we said
we're making this movie where we're
going to showcase
china in the future where the main
character joseph gordon-levitt when he
retires as a gangster
he wants to move to china because that's
where everybody in the world wants to be
they're like oh that's interesting we
said well what do you want your city to
look like 40 years in the future because
everybody wants to be there so let's
design it with you
so we actually use cg and design teams
to work with the shanghai municipal
government to create the backdrop that
would be
in all the scenes through cg renderings
um and a big part of that was the pudong
district which is across
the river from the bund harbor front and
you see photos of it with the
the big television spear and all the
gleaming glass buildings
so we built a bunch of buildings of
their future
that would showcase this amazing mecca
of where everyone wanted to be and
ultimately they signed off on that the
ccp thought it was amazing and then the
ccp said well what are you guys doing
about middle class jobs
and we said well we're going to shoot a
bunch of the movie over here and we're
actually not going to take
all of the crews from hollywood and the
crew members that we need
we're actually going to utilize your
people on the ground and anybody that's
a little
in over their skis we're going to
actually come in early and train them so
they can get up to speed
and work with us in a world-class manner
and when we leave
their skill sets are still going to be
there on the ground so you can help
utilize that to make your film industry
great which by the way now that i look
back at it we helped accelerate their
film industry so now it's a major
competitor to us but
at the time they thought it was
brilliant we got the job done
the movie ended up fantastic and because
of it
this normal movie that would have never
gotten into the market
we got into the market we got access
to their national holiday release a week
which is usually banned for anything
from outside of china but they
designated the movie as a local
production because we did so much with
china
and they allowed us to release it
against just their local movies which
was fantastic
and ultimately the movie was a top 10
movie that year so then we went on from
that looper case study which was
one step of the ladder to the next one
which was
what do we do now that we did a 35
million dollar movie and prove this
let's go after a 200 million dollar
movie and that's where
that movie poster behind me iron man 3
and marvel came into play
and so what's really interesting about
the looper case study i think is
um it sounds like you hit two of their
main concerns right one is we want china
to be
um kind of uh uh you know
highly sought after in terms of the
future view of it
and then two is or aspirational as the
word i was looking for
uh and then two is uh you actually were
able to uh create economic
impact on the ground uh and also skills
right so kind of help people move into
the middle class and then do that
in exchange what you know the the movie
producer the directors etc
ended up doing was changing the scene
changing some of the content whatever
um to kind of meet in a middle ground or
a compromise if you will right and so
um when you then do that you talked
about iron man 3
much bigger production walk us through
that example in terms of kind of what
the changes were made and what you guys
were looking to address so that
uh the movie would ultimately get green
lighted and allowed access into the
chinese market
yeah and i think well one of the parts
that you brought up there that's really
important is there's only so much you
can do in regards to pulling in a bunch
of people into the middle class with any
given project
but you talked about narrative and
messaging right
the ccp if they're going to give access
to anything from the outside
they want to make sure that either it's
doing something tangible like creating
real jobs
or it's something that they can showcase
as
hey populist look at what this movie is
doing it's making
all of us look amazing in the future we
are the country of the future
this is where we're going and us the ccp
are leading you there right keeps
everybody happy
iron man 3 was sort of the same
um case study yet uh it was
it involved a lot more layers of
convincing on
on my side of the pacific right you had
marvel and you had
um you know robert downey jr and disney
and various other
big filmmakers involved with the project
so a lot of the things that we were able
to ask the looper filmmaking crew to do
we weren't able to push through that
massive sort of
filmmaking village that was involved
with iron man 3
and i and i in the book i i give
examples of some of those crazy meetings
where
um there was even a moment uh well there
was one meeting where i was actually
trying to convince
marvel that um there's a kid in the
movie who sort of saves the day he's
he um the the movies about um how
tony stark feels in order to be the
person he is he has to be iron man and
ultimately he loses the power to be iron
man in the middle of the movie
um and almost dies and he's dragging his
iron man suit through the snow
about to die and this kid saves him by
bringing him into this warming hut and
nursing him back to life
and whatever and and then later in the
movie um
you find out one of his pieces of armor
is stuck in the shed and this kid has to
open the shed up so the armor can fly
out
and get to iron man so that he can save
the day
my idea was to use that
kid as the perfect relevancy touch point
to get the windower back in china
and the idea was to have him be
essentially the son of a ccp member
um who was on exchange in this country
uh senior level
ccp members actually do a lot of
research
on america by living in america for a
certain amount of time and they don't go
and live in
los angeles or new york or san francisco
they actually live in middle america and
xi jinping who wasn't running
china at the time but we knew he was
going to actually spent a lot of time in
iowa and that's actually how he got to
know branstad who's now the ambassador
to china
um so the thought was well what happens
if a guy like xi jinping
was living in the middle of america and
had a kid with him
and that kid chinese saved the day for
tony stark and iron man and it becomes
part of the plot of the movie
i thought it was brilliant um marvel
essentially in the meeting said um let
us think about it i come back in the
room about
20 minutes later and they go we're not
going to use that and i said why and
they're like
we don't want the sidekick of indiana
jones in this film
so that got shut down but they ended up
coming with an alternative
so what we did with that movie is
in in terms of looper case study was we
shot some of it on the ground in china
we brought in a guy named juan kashi who
played
essentially the chinese the vital
chinese role
in the movie in order to to get the
window back from the ccp
and then we we implemented various other
technological components
because the chinese love to be sort of
the forefront of technology
into the script so that we could
actually showcase
how this movie was putting china on a
certain pedestal in various ways
it was much more minimal of a disruption
in that
particular movie than it was with um
looper
and in fact it was so minimal that the
government in china
was pretty unhappy with it so we
actually had to make an extended cut of
footage
in order to please the the ministry of
propaganda in china to give us
access to the market which is a whole
another can of worms that i talk about
in the book
for sure and so um before we get to the
third example which is a point break one
of uh one of my favorite movies but
um the two examples we've talked about
already looper and iron man three what
are we talking about in terms of
financial performance
uh getting into china versus if you
hadn't gotten to china is this a
20 increase in revenue is this a 500
increase like
how does the chinese market and that
access change the financial
um kind of gain from uh for a movie
yeah well it's a great question and
obviously it's a very important one and
i will say one of the great things about
working with kevin feige and his team at
marble is they never once said hey if we
do this
how much more money are we gonna make
like it was always hey if we do this
does it make the movie better
does it fit into the marvel universe
does it make our fans feel okay about
putting it in there
does it harm our brand or hurt our brand
those are the questions they always ask
which is very
different from a lot of other business
leaders where it's like okay
we're game if it makes us x amount of
more money so
for one i want to compliment them on
that
but at the time they were true
antagonists to me
because it was making my life very
difficult now for the financial reward
of it all
when we made that deal marvel's biggest
grossing movie at the time was iron man
2 it made 20 million dollars in the
china market
when iron man 3 came out we broke every
single record in fact
we made 20 million dollars opening day
um the movie went on to gross 125
million dollars
just in the box office in china and much
more elsewhere
and then to date the last marvel movie
which is the final avengers movie
made 670 million dollars in that market
by itself
um marvel is now the most valuable
entertainment ip
on earth in the china market so the fact
that they went out of their way to try
to figure out smart ways to create
relevancy
and satisfy certain ccp objectives
had essentially teed up marvel over the
years to become
that valuable and it's only getting more
valuable as time goes on
yeah it's absolutely fascinating um and
so moving on to a point break
uh this is a remake of a of an old movie
um you you've told me that it didn't do
so hot in terms of the uh
the remake uh i love the movie just
because of the messaging behind it kind
of you know living your life fullest
uh every single day but talk a little
bit about um
kind of what you guys did there to uh to
be able to access the chinese market as
well
yeah well i think the better story with
point break is
is what we tried to do that turned out
not to be great
um it was sort of the reverse of of a
case study
but point break um and by the way
anybody that remembers the first one
um most people critically plan panned
the second one so i apologize in advance
for that
um i actually thought it was a pretty
cool movie we made a lot of money with
it
in china but elsewhere it didn't and it
probably would have been better that
we'd never made the movie to begin with
but when we were working on the script
to get it ready
for production we were looking at ways
to satisfy
the ccp objectives that we talked about
earlier and we came up with this really
interesting scene that would showcase
shanghai once again
and and showcase the skyline and just
make a really
cool sort of action sequence that would
also utilize their crew and everything
else on the ground
so the idea was in the pudong district
there's a 150-story building a
fictitious building
and it's gleaming glass and at the very
top of it
there happens to be a diamond dealer
broker up there
and our robin hood characters in point
break ride up the
freight elevator on motorcycles it opens
up
everybody looks there's a bunch of guys
in you know
helmets black dressed and hammers in
their hands and they're like what the
heck and then
boom they're driving straight out of
there at full speed and they start
knocking
all the diamond display cases with the
hammers breaking the glass
grabbing as many diamonds as they can
and everybody's
going oh my god screaming the security's
chasing after them and they keep driving
faster and faster and faster towards the
other side of the building
and obviously everybody's going well
obviously they're going to stop at some
point
but no they don't stop they keep
accelerating stealing diamonds along the
way
and boom they crash right out the
windows of the top floor of 150 story
building
well game set match no not at all they
had parachutes
they parachute across the river over the
bun harbor front over a bunch of the
markets peasants below
and from thousand feet up they release
all the diamonds to the peasants
and the peasants who are obviously poor
um
you know see these diamonds hit the
ground and they gather them up and it's
an amazing sort of robin hood
action sequence well the ccp did not
think that
in fact the ccp said if you put that in
the movie you will never get this movie
released in china and we said well why
is that and they said well two reasons
number one is they would have been
caught by the police before they even
got out of the building
that's number one and number two even if
they
did get out of that building and
released all those diamonds over the
peasants
not a single chinese peasant or a
chinese person would pick up those
diamonds because those diamonds weren't
theirs that is just simply not chinese
and i remember scratching our head going
wow
okay we didn't think about that one and
the beauty was
we love the action sequence so we kept
it in the movie we shot it in germany
instead but it was an interesting sort
of teaching moment where
sometimes american hubris and what you
think is really smart
um actually doesn't really translate in
the chinese ccpis
yeah it and it's so crazy to kind of see
uh almost the negotiation over some of
this content and i think that the
um the counter argument to this which i
know that you're not blind to
is uh when americans hear uh you know
the office of propaganda
or they think about censorship and that
type of stuff they get very queasy and
they say wait this is not
american right or this is not kind of
the approach that we normally would take
talk a little bit about kind of as you
were doing this what folks you knew were
saying to you kind of how you thought
about the work that you were doing
and then maybe how your opinions changed
over the last couple of years
well and like we've talked about offline
i mean one of the big
issues that when i look back at the fog
of war
that was really the 15 years i cover in
the book
we were under this tremendous mission
that we all believed in which was
globalism
and this mission that opening this
market
of 1.4 billion people no matter what it
took
was the smartest thing that you could do
as a capitalist
and somebody that was trying to create
opportunity for americans right
the more products and services we got
into that market
the more money there is to make and then
on top of it
you know we're spreading soft power
influence into the country
that was the mission that's what we
believed in and that's what guided me
through
various chirps in my ear through those
years including my wife who many times
said
well what's i i overheard that
conversation on the phone
why are you guys doing that like isn't
that sort of
not what americans are about or isn't
that sort of kowtowing to their
censorship or whatever it is and i was
like
jen jen jen you you don't understand
like we have to open this market like
this trust me this is the right way to
go and she's like okay
you know but i it just doesn't seem
right and
various other individuals did the same
thing through that and i talked i i hit
on that a couple times in the book
and what's really frustrating to me as
somebody who
thinks of myself as relatively
intelligent
is that that fog of war blurred me
massively to all the pandering cow
towing
and quite frankly the the wrong doings
we did for
overall long-term health of america
in opening that country there are
products and services and it wasn't
until
a couple days after daryl mori tweeted
out that support for hong kong last
october
where i suddenly woke up to it um i saw
that i was sitting on a
soccer sideline with a couple other
soccer dads watching our kids play
soccer
that tweet popped up on my phone um i
remember saying to one of the dads
whoa that's going to be a huge problem
for the nba in china he said why and i
said because
this guy i've never heard of him before
but he's the gm of
houston rockets and houston rockets
because of yao ming is one of the
biggest branded teams there and
the nba is always under scrutiny in
regards to anything that they're doing
that's not
ccp uh you know approved it's gonna be a
problem and i was right
um that happened over the course of like
six hours
you know they went from you know the
hero of china to the goat of china
and what i didn't see coming which
happened over the next
couple days was this wokeness that
occurred
across america red and blue people going
wait a minute wha why is the nba
stuttering over what their response is
in regards to
supporting somebody who exercised their
right of free speech on our land
about something that we do care about
which is the protesters and the rights
and the human rights of these hong kong
people
um why are we backtracking off of that
why are we not backing that why are we
staying silent why hasn't lebron said
anything
um and that was the moment where i'm
going
holy cow like everybody's complaining
about this pandering cow towing and this
sort of third rail issue problem that we
have with
china um and i was 100
complicit in it too and then i started
thinking about
all the book you know uh content that i
had written and i was thinking i'm gonna
have to address this in the book somehow
i don't want to mess around with the 15
years where i was
in that fog of war but i want to address
it
in the afterward and i also want to hit
some of those notes where people were
chirping in my ears and i was too
blinded to listen
so that's the moment where i realized it
and that's where i'm on this
crusade and mission today as literally
um i was on with pen america um this guy
james tagger who who wrote the pen
america report about hollywood's cow
towing to china last night on a podcast
and he's like you're literally the only
one in hollywood going on the record and
talking about this right now you are the
squeaky wheel
and i said i know i get it i'm
sacrificing a lot to do it but i believe
in it
and i know from the emails of support
and the different people that have
called me about it in the hollywood
community who
have said they can't talk about it
publicly um i know
i'm gonna be able to get them there to
be a squeaky wheel with me
and i also do see a way for us to do
that step approach engineering style
to get to a point where we do get to a
rebalanced relationship with china where
we feel okay as americans
opening that country to our products and
services
so a lot of people are going to hear
this and be like oh listen to this crazy
conservative guy who's basically worried
about
you know china china china china um
i don't think that you're actually a
conservative so maybe talk a little bit
about your political affiliations
and how this book has kind of transpired
the party lines
yeah well obviously i'm in hollywood
which
leans left and that wasn't the influence
of my political affiliation it was
actually my parents who are pretty
liberal and i've been a lifelong
democrat my whole life no one's actually
asked me on the spot
what what my political affiliation is
but i have no qualms about keeping it
quiet
um what's super frustrating about it
is if you look at all the different
things that are important to democrats
about china and some of the problems
that we're having with this bilateral
relationship
democrats should be all over the case i
mean from from human rights violations
to freedom of speech issues to
the decimation of our middle class and
labor class in this country
um it is just as democrat if republican
if not even more of a democrat issue
um unfortunately right now mostly the
right
is talking about it and for me i'm
nonpartisan on this issue this is a red
and blue issue we need to address
together
both parties and all americans um china
has
one message over there that they get
from the ccp through the ministry of
propaganda 1.3 billion people
not the public bureau or the very
well-off who can get around the firewall
on vpn but
1.3 billion people get one message over
there here in the us
we get two um or plenty of others but
for the most part you got msnbc and cnn
and rachel maddow et cetera and then you
got the
tucker carlson's and the fox news et
cetera on the other side
we need to at least with this particular
challenge
we need to all come together on it we
need to all be on message
and we need to be ready to you know
fight the long game
because china's already on message on it
and they do have 25 50 75 year election
cycles or
not even election cycles just mentality
whereas we have two to four year
election cycles where we think very
short term
so the bottom line is right now i'm
taking the platforms that are given to
me to get
this message out and i am pounding on
the door
on the left my side of the aisle to
allow me on those platforms too
to get this very important message out
and the fact is the way i wrote my book
um is a an appeal to a broad audience
like it is michael lewis memoir
colorful it's actually written a
three-act structure like a
movie script so that i could hopefully
appeal to as many readers as possible
that just want to engage in a great
story with great characters
but then also absorb some information
that i think is really powerful to have
in order to try to figure out as a voice
in this how we're going to address china
moving forward
yeah and one of the things that is
really
uh i think unexpected as we've talked
more and more
is you've got this framework around uh
a single centralized kind of cohesive
message coming out of china
and yet a uh almost competing
messaging coming out of the united
states and so what that leads to is
uh there's not a lot of collaboration
not a lot of cohesion
uh kind of in our response right and
we're seeing this with um
the potential banning of tick tock and
wechat and all this kind of stuff where
essentially china has really enforced a
very strict
great firewall on united states
technology companies
uh and in response now the united states
is potentially doing that back or
reciprocating that
kind of treatment of technology
companies talk a little bit about um
kind of this framework and why you think
the united states having this cohesive
response and message one is important
but also two
why do you think that it can actually
work well
number one is the cohesive message is
sort of interesting because
i've written a couple op-eds over the
last few months where i try to address
a given issue both through the eyes of
red and blue so for instance
um in shamath on on an interview with
you brought this
up back in april about this supply chain
dependence or this massive efficiency we
have in our economy
which is uh partially due to supply
chains being overseas and some of those
supply chains being in
countries that we don't necessarily have
the best relationship with
especially in times of crisis um china
is one of those
so one of the things that coveted
brought up was this idea that we have
massive supply chain issues that are
tied up in china
um so uh part of that involves
national security interests right the
pharmaceutical businesses
um and all of our antibiotics quite
frankly are
are made outside of this country and
most of them in china
if you look at red and blue and what
what gets them
excited gets their constituents excited
there's a
a a way to argue that
there's a come together on the supply
chain issue
on the red side the supply chain issue
could easily be defined as a national
security issue
and that's something that the republican
side gets very behind obviously the
democrats do too but it's more of a
republican side
on the blue side on the democrat side
that supply chain issue is also part of
the reason why our labor class our
middle class has been decimated we've
moved a lot of and in the case of
national
security issues or pharmaceuticals a lot
of those jobs are potential middle class
jobs
right it's not a t-shirt factory making
nike t-shirts it's
actually a real skilled position
that's involved with these different
manufacturing areas so
those things combining the venn diagrams
there you got national security and then
you got
labor and middle class you can get red
and blue on the same page
about trying to address that um and it's
the same thing that i look
even at the cultural side of things
where this pandering
of of china in order to get content in
there whether it's
movies or television or music or nike
shoes or
nba whatever it is there's a real
argument
not to fully decouple and say let's not
do that anymore
right because on the left side of of the
aisle
the blue you could say hey every time we
get a kid wearing a pair of nike shoes
every time they watch a movie
um every time they are uh you know
subjected to an nba player doing
something dazzling and talking about
america
there's that fantastic sort of
diplomatic tool
that culture creates as a clue between
the two superpowers
and then on the red side of it that
cultural exchange
and that effect that we have on their
populace
can be seen as a weapon right that
weapon is something that
creates more and more of an excitement
around democratic values and principles
um and might draw that populace to a
boiling point where they actually rise
up and
overtake the ccp right and it's
something that you could argue
we were doing in regards to injecting
culture into the ussr during the cold
war
or into various african states in the
50s when they were deciding whether to
go
communist towards the ussr or towards
free-market or
free democracies like the united states
i mean we used to send over black jazz
musicians
to some of those countries to showcase
the freedom of
artistic expression in order to get them
to be
want to be more like a democracy so
weapon democratic tool labor middle
class
you know national security supply chain
issues there are ways to get
red and blue together i 100 believe in
that
yeah and you previously mentioned to be
this idea that
um it's basically career suicide for
most people to step out and talk about
this right so if you're
an mba executive if you're a team owner
if you're a general manager if you're a
player
off-limits conversation right like
you're just not going to
uh really have a um a win in terms of
your career
now there's many people who are willing
to still talk about it because they see
something other than their career is
important but from a career perspective
not good
hollywood seems to be the same thing
even at the
corporation level right we see um you
know tech companies we see all kinds of
businesses
people do not want to talk about this
publicly because they see it as
basically no upside right and so what i
think we've seen
is uh every time somebody does talk
about it
they're almost alone on an island right
and when they talk about it
it's easy to get struck down by their
peers
by the media by uh the chinese media by
um you know just becoming unpopular with
the chinese people all that kind of
stuff
i think your argument is wait a second
if we keep sending kind of individual
people out there or individual companies
on their own to stand up and kind of
fight the fight by themselves
we're never going to win right that goes
back to that lack of cohesion
but if we all get together and take a
stand as a country
from the you know no name private
citizen
up to the biggest celebrity to the
largest corporations to
you know the halls of washington
together we can take a stand
and not only one protect each other
because kind of you've got power and
unity
but also actually make a difference and
force things to change
right yeah i mean um so
there's not a lot of people like i mean
obviously i can sell
books off of this squeaky wheel message
but
unfortunately that doesn't replace the
income i was making prior
um books are not that profitable but
um the message that i'm super passionate
about
has sort of overtaken what i want to do
as a person
so um that's an exception right now and
what we're seeing
is people that are putting their heads
in the sand
are doing it because they have a lot to
lose by saying something
the people that are coming out and and
saying this is a problem actually don't
have much to lose
or actually have a lot to gain from it
if you look at senator marco rubio or
josh hawley or
senator blackburn or bill barr or you
know uh
pompeo et cetera they're gaining either
political status from it they're getting
constituents excited around this red
meat idea and that helps them win
elections whatever it is right
they don't care that they can't get
business done in china because they
don't have business done in china
however to me that doesn't matter to me
the fact that they're putting it out
there
and making people aware of this problem
is just as great as what daryl mori did
in regards to getting me aware of the
problem and a lot of other people
like we need more of that whatever the
agenda is i don't care
where the people are staying quiet
that's the part where we have to work on
right so the more that uprising and that
soapboxing
gets people aware of this and want to
talk about it
the more pressure it's going to put on
those c-suite executives and the
investors and the different
you know shareholders of these companies
the goal is to get to a point
where it's not a whack-a-mole
sacrificial lamb
situation right if bob iger wants to
make a stand
you know he's going to decimate the
shanghai park in
in china he's going to screw up their
movie release schedule
it's going to be a real problem for
disney in one of their highest growth
areas
on their balance sheet investors
shareholders will then remove eiger from
that job or it's actually jpeg
and and then replace them with somebody
else who's willing to put their head in
the sand and not pretend like this
doesn't exist
so the whack-a-mole doesn't work it just
sacrifices
certain individuals and then they're
replaced so the only way to deal with it
is strength in numbers and one of the
things that i recommended to
on the podcast last night with the pan
america
lead on this hollywood cow towing
situation is you get the mpa
evolved which is the the trade
association for
all the studios and they essentially
back
the idea of say right now paramount is
dealing with this problem of having a
taiwanese flag on the back of tom
cruise's jacket in the reboot of
of top gun um they have relented
to ccp pressure they're taking the
taiwanese flag off
for the china market i'm okay with that
that's censorship within their borders
the problem is is china is pushing them
to remove it for the rest of the world
to see
so they're essentially using that movie
to impress upon the rest of the world
that there is no such thing as a
independent taiwan
um that's propaganda and censorship and
soft power influence that we shouldn't
put up with
if paramount stands up to that paramount
will be blackballed for a couple years
in the market
they'll be replaced by universal movies
or disney movies or whatever
so paramount right now is going to give
in and let the ccp
dictate what they do with that jacket
what we need is all the hollywood
studios to say
we stand behind the freedom of artistic
expression that paramount needs to stand
behind
and all of us will support them in this
in this decision and when they say they
are going to
let that cut be seen around the world
that you don't want
ccp we're gonna guaran we're gonna have
you guarantee that you don't retaliate
against them and if you do retaliate
against them
then you will get zero hollywood movies
from us
until the time that you redeem them back
into your good graces
and that's the only way we're gonna have
the ability to push them
and the reason why i know this works and
we were talking offline about this
is that china is practical china in a
way
is like a teenager they will keep
pushing
and the parent that says oh you know
what boys will be boys girls will be
girls
let's not let's not stop them there
that's just going to create a problem or
whatever
well the teenager is going to push again
and it's going to push again
it's 11 15 at night they haven't showed
up the turf used at 11.
it's 11 30 the next time it's 11 45 the
next time it's midnight the next
time china's the same way they see an
ability to push on an
area that they can get more and more
influence on they're going to keep doing
it
and it's not until they get pushed back
where they get practical and they go you
know what
let's stop that's as far as we'll go and
an example of that
is this wolf warrior diplomacy which
they had implemented
um say six months ago around covid um
a lot of it where they were trying to
show that their form of government was
much better
in dealing with covet and they handled
it much better than other
democracies and then they have the belt
and road initiative that they've been
pushing and various other things they've
been pushing on various countries around
the world
well australia stood up against that
uh many european nations stood up
against that
united states stood up against that and
even though we haven't gotten an
official statement out of china
that wolf warrior diplomacy pushed from
the foreign ministry that have been
going on
strong for six months has disappeared
over the last month
and to me that's an example of strength
in numbers
caused them to pull themselves back from
something they kept aggressively pushing
forward on so i know
from that example and various others
that i've seen over time
we can do this but we can't do it
single-handedly we can't do it
just republicans are just democrats and
we can't just do it all at once we got
to check boxes as we go
through the process is it fair to say
that
um this is something that the hollywood
um
kind of production studios the ceos you
know
the top eight or ten of them could get
together decide hey this is what we're
going to do we're going to take a stand
uh and if they came out together a lot
of this would go away
or do you think that's not enough i
think
um i think right now there's still this
belief that's going to go away
it has before and i think there's that
belief there and i think there's even a
belief that
um once the november election is done
and
and you know and talking from
hollywood's mindset they
100 believe biden's gonna win that when
biden takes over
you know this china thing is gonna get
sort of figured out and we'll go back to
a relative
normal um my feeling is
no matter who wins we've done so much
damage with the relationship that's not
going to go back to normal
there's a lot of things that we woke
china up to the same way they woke us up
to
where they're going wait a minute we got
to get more sufficient over here as
as as a nation we need to protect
ourselves from this or this or
from the next crazy president or
whatever they want to do
they've woken up to it we've woken up to
it so things are not going to be normal
as long as the populace keeps putting
pressure on hollywood i think
hollywood's going to have to deal with
it and if hollywood
doesn't deal with it on the offense and
proactively
my guess is that what they will get
called to washington dc
and put on the stand in a soapbox sort
of way to actually say what they're
gonna do about it which as we know is
probably not the most constructive way
to get it done i've i've been
dealing and working with various
individuals on the china task force
um with congress in fact i was on
congressman mike gallagher's podcast
recently
my recommendation is that they reach out
to c-suite executives in hollywood
and have private meetings essentially
talking about the pressures
that are causing them to be quiet to be
crickets on this
issue and and allow the congressional
members to talk about why
they're getting pressured to actually be
vocal about it and try to figure out
where the venn diagrams
you know co-exist and where there might
be
interesting baby steps to get to some
place
where the populace calms down a little
bit about this cow towing
and pandering and actually hollywood can
talk more about it freely
knowing that they have the weight of the
nation protecting them from any sort of
retaliation so
i know it's possible but we have to have
the dialogue like
the third rail issue has to disappear
we have to speak openly about it we
can't pretend it's going to just go away
because this time it is not
and maybe it's completely shocked and it
does but this time it feels real
and it feels like we're going to have to
do something to address it
how prevalent is this in hollywood like
if you got to put a number on is this
fifty percent of movies are dealing with
this and having content changed is this
eighty percent ten percent like what
what percentage of movies do you think
are being affected by this
i would say outside of netflix and
netflix tried to get in that market for
many years and i think they've come to
the realization that hey they don't need
china and b they're never going to get
in there because there's competitors
that are chinese already that the ccp is
backing
so netflix even last year had a
documentary about the one child policy
netflix doesn't care everybody else
has massive business interests in china
so every piece of content
by every division inside all these
vertically integrated companies
is thinking about china and is
premeditatedly
or you know working ahead of the script
level
or during the script level to avoid
antagonizing the ccp
in any way now let's face it
90 percent of all movies probably don't
even tread anywhere near
the kind of stuff that's going to
antagonize china at all
probably out of that other 10 say 5
they would have to go out of their way
with ver certain plots to make it
antagonistic
and make it a problem but that other 5
is actually truly either being
proactively
avoiding certain things or making sure
they avoid
things that they're aware of that are
censored or
sensitive in that market and then the
other half of that five percent is
actually proactively trying to create
more relevancy for that market because
next year
that will be the largest market on earth
so
to not pay attention to it as a movie
maker as a television maker as any sort
of content maker in hollywood
is a fool's errand it has to be done
that is where the growth prospects are
and now that covet has disrupted a lot
of the economics involved with
how you monetize content china's become
even more important
yeah and then has the federal reserve uh
play into this right you previously said
that there uh there's a risk that
they're
lulling us into uh a war uh with china
to elaborate on a little bit or explain
kind of how you think about the federal
reserve and some of the actions there
well so there's
and and you've talked about this in
interviews where you
you realize like there's certain things
that happen to you in life and you're
going oh my god i better learn
all i can about this or it's going to
happen to me again
and in the book i talk about a very low
point in my life in 2008 where
my family my wife and i had lost
everything um
after lehman brothers went bankrupt and
and that was a point where i decided i'm
going to try to learn as much as i can
from from sort of a spectator level
about wall street and how the financial
system works and of course
you learn a lot about central banks and
how that's all
all governed and one thing that i think
is
is has happened drastically over the
last year
um and kovit's a big part of it and i'm
not
saying the fed is doing wrong things but
i think the amount of duct tape
that they've wrapped around the u.s
economy right now in order to save it
from a covered depression
has created this massive prozac effect
from anything affecting u.s markets u.s
stock markets
and for bad or or good we've
looked at u.s stock markets especially
president trump
as the ultimate scoreboard in the game
of how is america doing
um and if you go back to last summer and
i was actually
on the ground in china with three
congressional uh three congressional
members on this delegation trip where we
were in hong kong and also in china
every day there was a tweet um more of a
barking
kind of tweet from from president trump
about what he was planning to do
in order to fix the trade imbalance
between the u.s and china and in fact
one time
he tweeted out i hereby command all u.s
businesses to remove their business from
china
and the markets tanked like 800 points
literally within 30 minutes of that
tweet
and then over that weekend they were all
in spain talking about
um at the g8 summit or whatever talking
about whether he meant that or not and
then the market sort of came back
but that type of market reaction for
just a
a tweet that was barking not biting
barking
um created a massive downswing
in the dow and the s p and the nasdaq
and those type of downswings wake
everybody up to
whoa that might have been pushing it too
far and by the way i would argue it's
not pushing it too far but
it wakes everybody up it's that canary
in the coal mine where okay are we
sure we want to go down this path
because that's going to keep happening
if we do
now we're in a position where we're not
just barking we're actually biting
against china we are creating major
plays
against china that affect
you know journalism that affect rights
that affect
banking sector that affect tech
companies that affect
you know supply chain issues like real
actions
that cause real ramifications both
negative and positive
the markets have not reacted to any of
them
none and to me that's a real problem
because that lack of any sort of
scoreboard
change due to what we are doing with
china right now
is prozacking us into a more and more
extreme
approach to china where we don't even
notice
that we're getting more extreme and
eventually that extreme approach is
going to get to a point where we do
actually enter a cold war which is
something my book is
very very proactive about us avoiding
and even worse we could move into a
kinetic war right so
i feel like the fed is
creating a situation where we're not
even able to understand
how serious this is getting yeah
well they're definitely pushing us that
way i think um the last thing i want to
finish up talking about
is uh recently uh trump and
the administration came out with uh two
executive orders that essentially banned
uh american businesses from doing
business transactions with
uh both bite dance which owns tick tock
uh and then 10 cent
which owns wechat and a few others and
uh while we've been recording this
actually it looks like apple has removed
uh
fortnite uh from the app store which i
think is kind of related to this and so
any thoughts around kind of um those
executive orders
and uh those seem to be more bite than
bark
right and people are kind of starting to
respond um
and really take this a little bit more
seriously
uh maybe that is because they fully
agree with
hey we need to stand up and and you know
can i do the quote-unquote right thing
or maybe it's literally just out of uh
kind of self-preservation and i'm not
going to go against the us government
because i don't want to
you know fight my own government while
also having to deal with this issue but
for whatever reason
it looks like maybe businesses are
taking this seriously so kind of what
were your thoughts when you saw those
executive orders
and do you think that kind of moves the
needle in any way
yeah well bike dance is an interesting
one or a tick tock because
in a way if you're looking at election
coming up and and
president trump's looking to get
reelected and that's uh
he's looking for you know sort of red
meat angles
tick tock is something that a lot of
people use or
a lot of people's kids use so it's one
of those things where
it really can create a lot of attention
grabbing in regards to how hardcore he's
getting on china
um so i can see exactly why
he's going after it in a political sense
in a technology sense i mean let's face
it there
is a lot of potential big data that is
being
stored from tick tock up primarily from
teenagers
that will eventually be influential
voters or
people of influence in the united states
at some point
and i would argue that there probably is
a real potential for that big data
to be mined by ai at some point and be
used against us somehow
i would also argue there's probably
other companies that might be
even better places to to look in regards
to
um activating big data against us
in a much quicker fashion but tick-tock
i could say and
you guys you know the tech companies
probably know way better than i do
about the reality of that threat wechat
to me is actually a real threat on
chinese in general because
wechat even though it's not used as much
by
u.s citizens um almost all the
expat chinese use it for everything from
you know purchasing power to sending
money back home
to various other communicative uh
ways to to deal with all the different
people around the world that they
they have a lot of companies utilize it
with their expats over here
so i feel like it's very punishing on
the chinese people both
on the ground in china in hong kong and
elsewhere around the world particularly
in the us
um and it's also got a lot of really
um sensitive material on it too so
it seems like there's a secure you know
a security issue there but it also feels
like there's a
um a vengeful type of action in regards
to wechat itself
um and i'd also argue that there's a
real opportunity
in both of these to create about a more
balanced or actually even an unfair
pro-america um sort of action that
occurs
that we've seen in china for instance
china saying
google or facebook you can't come in
here and allowing
um its own companies to sort of grow and
blossom
from that prohibition i could see the
same thing happening here where
you're essentially taking what tick tock
built and forcing them to sell it to
an american company and allowing that
american company whether it's microsoft
or somebody else
to benefit from it um the same thing
with taking
wechat out of here and allowing its
competitors to take off in a much better
way i mean it's a tactic china is used
against us
um and it seems like many could argue
that it's rightful for us to take the
same tactic against china
yeah i think you nailed it when it was
kind of there's
a mantra and a belief of globalism and
it feels like now you're getting a
nationalism
type approach and that is an approach
that china has used very effectively
um and and really changed the trajectory
of their country in many ways
uh by using that strategy and so now
we're getting this kind of
uh yin and yang or almost negotiation
between nationalism and globalism here
in the united states and
it feels like that's kind of the main
show if you will in terms of
how a lot of this will play out it's
just which one of those mindsets or
approaches ends up actually
um kind of you know reigning supreme if
you will
well it's a you know it's interesting
because shamath on on an interview with
you was talking about the
efficiencies of this supply chain and
how it's it's sort of prone to
um deflation right and and if we want to
inflate ourselves out of some of these
problems
um you know moving supply chains back
here making those supply chains more
expensive for
the companies that are creating those
goods and services and then thusly more
expensive for the consumers
yet also creating jobs that hopefully
allow for us a thriving job market that
allow people to raise wages through
competition of their services um
it's an interesting sort of positive
feedback loop because
in a way you're addressing some of the
issues of deflation
by dealing with national security
interests
or various other labor middle class
problems
and then at the same time you're going
to create a more thriving middle class
and a more
middle layer of our economy which will
ultimately make the economy
much healthier in the long run and china
seems to be at the center of both of
those issues so
um you know it's why i'm out there
being that squeaky wheel but then on top
of it i refuse to be
just a squeaky wheel just a person
that's out there calling people
out i have real solutions
i'm not saying they're all right but
there are baby sep
steps approaches which we've talked
about offline before you know
whether it's getting the wto designation
from developing to developed
to getting the sec to apply standard
accounting practice rules to these
state secret hiding behind soes that are
trying to get access to our capital
markets
to simple things like um turning over
and changing the quota on
movies getting into the country from 34
to an unlimited sort of capital
capitalistic version of whatever that
market dictates
to their return of a box office um which
presently is at 25
of every dollar get it up to the global
norm of 50
and that's just one industry microcosm
there are a bunch of boxes we can check
in every industry
um there are big macro issues where we
can check boxes
and over the course of time just like
how we made things worse over 40 years
and didn't really notice it
we can do the same thing in a positive
sense where over the course of time
we're just
checking all these boxes and and soon
before we know it we're actually at this
utopian
rainbow version of a bilateral
relationship with china
i get it that's sort of pie in the sky
but we can get we can make progress 100
can make progress and we can do it if
we're unified
absolutely uh before we get into the
rapid fire questions to end it
uh where can people find your book
feeding the dragon
yeah so feeding a dragon you'll see in
bookstores or on
amazon i also have a website called
feedingthedragonbook.com
um and then i'm on twitter at the dragon
feeder and i love having that exchange i
just got on there a couple months ago
but i'm having a blast with it
yeah and i think uh for those that are
interested uh a lot of what chris and
i've talked about today
is obviously in the book he touches on a
number of these issues but
uh it's not written in what i'll call
kind of an academic sense he
described earlier kind of it's a much
more entertaining
kind of sit on the edge of your seat
type read
that's filled with stories and you know
he won't say this but i will he's a very
good storyteller so
i think that people will just generally
enjoy the book but but also
really unpack a lot of these ideas and
kind of see the real world examples of
how this stuff has uh
has played out and frankly i think um
one of the takeaways from the book is
just
it is so much more prevalent than people
realize and when they see the examples
they
you know similar to what your wife said
wait a minute that sounds weird
right or that that is that that isn't
something that i would have thought
happened in america
um so definitely go check that out and
it's feedingthedragonbook.com
um all right two questions then you
could ask me one two
to finish up uh first question what is
the most important book you've ever read
other than your own
um well it's pretty it's
it's a little bit academic but it i i
read um
liars poker back when i was just getting
out of college and then i read it like
another 15 times before i embarked on
this
this book and i combined that with
reading uh phil knight's book shoe dog a
couple times because i really wanted to
get an idea of how like for instance
michael lewis took
a subject that a lot of people didn't
know much about wall street
and he made it into something that i
really loved
paige turning in and it was a really
exciting sort of first person account of
it
and then phil knight also did a great
job of teaching lessons through his
journey in chew dog
so um those were very influential to me
um especially at this point in my career
second questions more fun aliens
believer or non-believer well
um i went to cornell university and i
had the pleasure of seeing carl sagan
talk there and obviously i grew up
watching
all those cosmos shows on pbs
i find it very difficult knowing that
there's billions and billions of
universes out there in in our in in this
amazing sort of uh or galaxies out there
in this amazing universe of ours so
i give it a 100 belief that there's
extraterrestrial life out there i have
no doubt about it
a hundred percent i love it you could
ask me one question to finish up what's
the uh what's the one question you got
for me
well i i just i'm i love
your your conviction on bitcoin in fact
when you go up against the shark tank
guys or andrew ross sork and then
they're just like such naysayers about
it you still stick to your guns on it
and i wonder with covid and we talked
about the fed and central bank
policy right now and it's sort of just
been amplified from what it already was
doing
do you feel like this bet you made
going back to whatever 2016
is even more strong of a convicted you
know conviction
bet that you have now going forward like
is everything the fed doing just making
you feel like
oh my god bitcoin why didn't i get into
this in 2012.
yeah i think it's um it's one of these
interesting uh kind of perspectives
where
uh you got to be careful that when you
put such a large portion of your net
worth into an asset like you don't want
to just become
so biased that the only data you find is
the data that confirms how smart you are
right and so i spent a lot of time
trying to think about like what's the
data that disproves it
um unsurprisingly like i don't find much
um and last year i went through this big
exercise in like may
june and into july really just thinking
about like what was going to happen in
the global macro environment and how
would that play out
for uh bitcoin and so a couple of times
i literally wrote saying
you know look we're in kind of the late
cycles of
uh this bull market i don't know when it
ends i don't i don't have kind of a
magic eight ball or anything like that
but there's just a lot of warning signs
right you could see it with
um you know even into like q3 q4 the um
repo markets had a lot of kind of
structural issues there was inverted
yield curves there was
you know high level of ceos leaving
their jobs like it just
felt like it's getting frothy right and
so when that happened i said look the
only thing that the central banks have
is they've got two tools
they can manipulate interest rates where
they can print money i think they're
going to do both
uh they're going to manipulate the rates
down i had no clue they would go to zero
but i just thought they would go down
um and i figured they would print money
because we're just a country that an
economy that's addicted now to that
monetary stimulus
would have never guessed that they would
print multiple trillions of dollars in
you know three or four months right um
and so what i think really kind of
played out in that thesis was
if they're going to drop rates they're
going to print money and timing wise
that's all going to hit around
90 days give or take of the bitcoin
having or that supply shock like
that should serve as rocket fuel for
bitcoin over the coming you know 18 to
24 months
and so that was really the thesis um
obviously
you know fast forward today we have the
benefit of high tight uh they dropped
rates much more aggressively they
printed money much more aggressively and
that bitcoin having occurred
and so if you kind of look at just data
points year-to-date performance stocks
are flat
gold's up about 25 30 bitcoins up about
60
um and so it's kind of like uh paul
tudor jones recently called like the
fastest horse
so they're gonna print all this money
you're gonna get uh a bunch of investors
run into the inflation hedge assets
it's just a question then of like which
one goes up the most right in us dollar
value and so his belief was that bitcoin
is probably going to be that i tend to
agree with them
um but but i think it's also one of
these things where you start to look at
um the macro trend definitely is kind of
wind at your back and
frankly should carry the bitcoin price
much higher in my opinion
but then there's these like more micro
events so today
uh as we're recording this uh there was
an announcement that
uh a number of federal agencies fbi and
a couple of others
uh basically broke down identified
and shut down uh a number of terrorist
kind of
uh i think they called it cyber enabled
money networks
which essentially was people had put up
websites you know whether it was isis or
al qaeda or
whatever they were and saying hey you
know we're gonna go and
commit violence in the world and it
falls along our thought process so send
us
uh bitcoin in order to be able to do
that right
and and i think in some cases they even
said it's untrackable you know with
instructions on how to do it and all
this kind of stuff
so like in those situations like that's
not good right
in the sense of um now you get headlines
where people are talking about
bitcoin and terrorism financing of
course the articles never mentioned like
the you know two trillion dollars a year
that's laundered in us dollars or
all of the cash that's used for you know
terrorist financing but i do think like
those micro
uh events are worth one paying attention
to and and those are actually the ones i
spend
more time kind of just thinking through
like what is the ramifications of this
because the macro stuff like it you know
i i would bet everything i have that the
federal reserve and the u.s government
is going to have to come up with another
stimulus package
and they're in a deadlock today but like
they're gonna have to figure it out
because if they don't the kind of impact
on tens of millions of americans will
literally cause a revolt
right and so you kind of get in these
worlds of like the macro stuff
is pretty easy i think to call out like
here's what they're going to do
now investors have to navigate what are
the impact on asset prices
when how you know how severely um what
should you protect versus capitalize on
like
those are the harder decisions um and
then the ones that you know obviously
kind of change a lot of this analysis is
the unforeseen things like
today with with um you know this bitcoin
and terrorism stuff so
you know generally i think conviction is
much higher today than it was
six months ago um but you know i i've
i've learned over the years don't be too
uh too confident because things can you
know literally change overnight and i
think we've seen that with
you know tick tock and wechat for you
know one executive order and next thing
you know completely different ball games
so
i think that's kind of the way that i
look at it yeah i agree i mean the the
news cycle and
just the events seem to be on a dog
years
like multiple level of of frequency
nowadays so
um i even think of the november election
that you know
in the old days that you you could
probably pick who's going to win
today and feel really solid about it but
knowing how fast everything changes
uh it's almost like impossible to even
know
i i uh i saw a meme on the internet so
before people freak out this was you
know somebody trying to be funny and i
don't remember who posted it but
basically they were like you know who
would have guessed that in the united
states our presidential candidates would
both be over the age of 70
right you know both be accused of sexual
assault but you know
and they just like went down the line
and they were like this is the best that
we have
right and uh regardless of what side of
the aisle you're on et cetera i think
there's a lot of people just saying
you know look i have no clue who's gonna
win right because it is somewhat of a
toss up you got a lot of uncertainty
economically with public health crisis
you know things like with the
relationship with china um so you know
again
i'm i'm not betting on on who's going to
win that one i'll just kind of wait to
see how it plays out
it's going to be an interesting few
months for sure
all right guys that is uh mr chris
fenton please go get the book
feedingthedragonbook.com fantastic read
and thank you so much for your time
we'll have to do this again chris
yeah thanks for having me back it was a
real pleasure humbled